English
[Music]
version Look at that yay he wants to eat
everything already
[Music]
you need your own bucket
[Music]
big chilling
[Music]
towards the airport we have the ocean
waves playing
but it's because this little guy
is sleeping now all that
trick-or-treating wiped him out also
like he totally was really late on his
map
we're just trying to fit everything in
this morning though was crazy because we
had to take Maya to the vet she hasn't
been eating she recently got surgery
surgery day let's take a look at your
little growth so Maya has had this
growth on her side feels like three
little balls right here
you can kind of see it sticking out
first noticed it maybe I don't know a
month ago now took her to the vet had
her checked out she seems healthy
otherwise other than this growth and so
the idea maybe is that it's benign it's
just a growth but we're gonna cut it out
today and we're surge rescheduled and
they're gonna take a look at it and see
if it's benign or what's the other word
malignant and uh we'll go from there
stand it up
forming surgery and now she's healing
Maya you just got back from the vet are
you okay you have your little IV right
that's the IV
and they shaved your back crazy
yeah oh poor baby girl oh my God should
you not be so active oh my goodness
look at those stitches
oh my God
[Music]
what's up
soda's not like Maya right now
he's growling right now
hey be nice
she just got surgery anyway we took her
to the event this morning because we
were really concerned that she wasn't
eating she was throwing up all the meds
that we were giving her oh yeah it's
time for your medicine oh my sweet Crow
also like she came home with some fleas
from the vet so that was annoying but
they gave her some flea medication and
they gave us the results to the testing
of the growth and it turns out that it's
a what is it
soft tissue sarcoma so apparently it was
gonna turn cancerous or something and so
luckily we caught it in time so it
didn't spread to the rest of her body
she's gonna be recovering well we are
currently headed to the airport because
we're picking up mama and yay
Casey just gave me a thumbs up because I
said it correctly so we're picking them
up and they're spending a few days here
and then they're gonna head off on a
road trip because they've been doing
tons of traveling which is so awesome
for them they just get to just reap the
event or what is it reap the fruits of
their labor or how does it how do you
say it whatever they enjoying their life
which is amazing
just got back from Argentina and they're
heading to Vietnam and they're just jet
setting the world it's amazing but yeah
so there's gonna stop by for a few days
spend some time with us they're gonna go
trick-or-treating with us later today so
yeah it's a nice happy Halloween
hi I got a 360. nice hey how are you
welcome
[Music]
oh let me help you Mom
oh you will go cranky you only slept for
30 minutes
all right nice and fed
he's observing
um
remember
do you remember me
it's just scary yeah
all right so we just got to my parents
Hotel our house is like completely
filled now with like all the Lucas
things and Luca has his own bedroom so
we don't have the space to
have about that time to get a bigger
house I guess anyways Tiff and Luca uh
they went inside too because Luca's been
a little fussy he thinks his teeth are
coming in so super cute he just bottom
teeth already came in and now it's like
upper teeth I think are coming in so
he's been super super fussy so Tiff
decided to take him out and uh go on a
little field trip to the hotel room but
since I'm alone right now I'm gonna take
a chance to say a huge huge huge thank
you to Helix sleep for sponsoring
today's video like always we're super
excited to partner up with you like
sleep because they just make the best
premium mattresses they can customize it
to fit your specific needs and the best
part is they ship it to your door you've
been using Helix mattresses for a year
and a half now we got it like last July
most recently decided to upgrade to a
king-size mattress because we wanted
more space in the bed to roll around
with Luca or take naps with Luca we've
decided to upgrade to a king-size
mattress and once again we went with
Helix and the reason why we always go
with Helix now is because Helix offers a
quiz for you to take to figure out what
kind of mattress fits your sleeping
preferences and your body type he likes
so cool they they actually accommodate
to the type of sleeper you are whether
you're a back sleeper a side sleeper
toss and turn in the quiz you can tell
it your preferred firmness or if you
wake up with back pains the Helix quiz
would actually take that into
consideration as well but the best part
I would say is since Tiff and I are
married the Helix quiz can actually take
into account not just one sleeper but
two sleepers so if you and your partner
have deferring opinions on How firm a
bed should be no problem now based on
our results Helix matches up with the
Helix Moonlight absolutely love the bed
super super soft spacious like I always
say I didn't know what bad sleep was
until I had good sleep because of Helix
I didn't realize my back was tight when
I wake up from sleep until sleep on the
Helix bed and I'm like oh you know what
oh this is how it's supposed to feel
when you wake up if you had a good sleep
but anyways it delivers straight to your
door with free shipping in the US and
you come in a box so it's super easy to
set up they also have a 100 night sleep
trial so you get more than three months
to figure out whether you like the Helix
mattress or not and if you don't they'll
actually come pick it up and give you a
full refund plus mattresses come with a
10 year warranty see and they offer for
flexible payments and financing so good
sleep is never far away I absolutely
love my Helix I think you will too check
out Helix that are linked below or visit
helixsleep.com Tiff case and get up to
200 off your Helix mattress plus two
free pillows all right I think they're
coming back out time to go pick up Isaac
our other son and go eat some
Chinese food because every time my
parents are in town Chinese food every
time you go visit them Chinese food
every time we cook at home with them
Chinese food but I don't got a problem
with that because I absolutely love
Chinese food it looks good do you
remember me give me a smile
thank you
[Music]
I know
[Music]
are you still cranky he's a cranky boy
he's teething I think because last night
he was not going to sleep how he has
been usually I had to get on some
Tylenol to like relax because he would
just keep like like that was his mouth
he's happy one second
be nice
[Music]
you know what it is it's the onesie when
we went to the pumpkin patch it was in a
bad mood and now Halloween Day wearing
the same one day he's in a bad mood
again yeah that's what it is it's a
Halloween onesie
oh my gosh
Come on Thursdays
[Music]
oh my God
I gave him one of these this is what
he's eating he likes it that's the first
time he actually ate it all the other
times I tried giving it to him he's like
[Music]
[Music]
oh cutie
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy Halloween
my mom on Halloween she decided to work
I know I love it helping us give out
candy at our own house trick or treat
oh here you go
you want me to drink a chicken yeah
yeah for one there we go
[Laughter]
a little hand
drop it
yes drop it drop it no
close okay happy Halloween happy
Halloween no sugar for you until you're
too we're collecting this for your big
brother that's right yeah and then once
once you're old enough then you can have
some okay exactly that's what we're
doing we're gonna save all this for him
two years from now no it's not gonna be
good
[Music]
hi
welcome
trick or treat happy Halloween happy
Halloween
Oh you mean Captain Jack
yes you can get the treat would you like
a nibble yeah
oh
I know I'm ugly
oh he got scared
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]